das was ein britisches forschungsteam
jetzt in der antarktis entdeckt hat ist
wirklich ungewöhnlich eine fläche von
50.000 quadratkilometern eis ist bereits
abgesagt zurückbleiben riesige
schmelzwasser sehen die erklärung dafür
sind wohl radioaktive gesteine die sich
unter der eisschicht befinden und das
eis von unten nach oben schmelzen lassen
was waren bisher zu dieser mysteriöse
anomalie unter dem eis weiß und warum
diese entdeckung und die tragische
folgen wenn die ganze erde haben könnte
jetzt bei klicks um science-fiction
herzlich willkommen einsatzteam des
britischen polarforschers programms
british antarctic survey kurzplatz eine
region in der ostantarktis überflug
trauten die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler wohl ihren eigenen augen
nicht denn dort war eine eisfläche von
gigantischem ausmaß nämlich etwa fünfmal
so groß wie berlin ja abgesagt deutlich
dezimiert das radar strömte stattdessen
riesige schmelzwasser sehen unter dem
eis auf die sich offensichtlich
kilometer weit erstreckt und die
darüberliegenden eisschichten sacken
also immer weiter nach unten habt die
ursache für all das sind nach vermutung
der expertin experten wohl ungewöhnliche
radioaktive gesteine die eben für diese
großen schmelz zonen sorgen diese lassen
die basis des ice quasi von unten nach
oben schmelzen dazu tom jordan der
hauptautor der aktuellen studie
dies war ein wirklich aufregendes
projekt denn hier haben wir eine der
vielleicht letzten noch unerforschten
regionen unseres planeten erkundet
unserer ergebnisse waren ziemlich
unerwartet der friede leute der meinung
waren dass diese regierung der antrag
des aus uralten und kalten gestein
besteht die die eisfläche darüber wenig
beeinflussen
dieses phänomen ist laut des
forschungsteams allerdings nicht
unbedingt eine neue entwicklung die
eisschmelze die jetzt beobachtet wurde
könnte demnach schon seit tausenden oder
sogar millionen jahren im gange sei
dennoch könnte das zusätzliche
schmelzwasser in der eisdecke der region
in zukunft viel anfälliger für äußere
faktoren wie eben den klimawandel machen
so die befürchtung der fachleute zu
geben ist es laut der aktuellen studie
äußerst wahrscheinlich dass solche
lokalen anomalien in der ostantarktis
weit verbreitet sein könnten und das
können so zu einem großen problem werden
denn um vorherzusagen wie viel eis an
den polen verloren geht und welche
folgen das war
weit haben könnte braucht es exakte
daten doch die aktuelle entdeckung zeigt
dass wir in diesem zusammenhang noch
lange nicht alles auf dem schirm haben
die großen schmelz zonen in der
ostantarktis beispielsweise sind in
keiner berechnung enthalten doch auch
ohne dieses neu entdeckte phänomen ist
das problem des schnellstens in der
antarktis groß ja wir berichten hier bei
pixum science fiction immer wieder
darüber
er ist im sommer 2018 hatte ein
forschungsteam der university leeds eine
besorgniserregende botschaft verkündet
demnach hat die antarktis nämlich von
2012 bis 2017 im mittel 219 milliarden
tonnen eis pro jahr verloren
eine riesige zahl und fast dreimal so
viel wie in den jahren davor das muss
man sich mal vorstellen das eisschild
der antarktis hat seit 1992 also
insgesamt etwa 3 millionen tonnen eis
verloren
mit dieser menge könnte man ganz
deutschland und acht meter hoch mit
wasser bedecken
doch eben nicht nur die reine
wassermenge an sich macht den
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern so große angst sondern
eben auch die geschwindigkeit 40 prozent
des verlustes passierten der studie
zufolge in den vergangenen fünf jahren
ja denken wir mal den worst case dann
nämlich wenn das gesamte antarktis
schmelzen würde der globale
meeresspiegel würde dann um unglaubliche
58 meter ansteigen eine katastrophe
nicht nur für die küstengebiete auf der
erde wir stehen also kurz vor alarmstufe
rot denn schon jetzt sind einige
veränderungen in der antarktis nicht
mehr rückgängig zu machen so kurios die
jetzt entdeckten heißen quellen auf den
ersten blick also erscheint umso klarer
steht auch fest dass sie dringend
genauer erforscht werden müssen wenn es
neues dazu gibt der fahrer das natürlich
hier oder auch auf dem englischen kanal
denn da gibt es heute und immer wieder
videopremieren making plastic front
plastic waste bioplastics wird solution
to global solution sehr interessante
lösung für unsere plastikmüll probleme
ich dafür übrigens hier unbedingt
klicken
ich freue mich auf euch auf dem
englischen kanal stay tuned co2